was that game you guys were playing
white elephant but very competitive
right oh [ __ ] I've never seen that yeah
rock paper scissors with your body yeah
so everyone brings a gift that's worth
150 200 $200 and you put on it in a what
a circle a pile they put it all in a
palette big ones
yeah wrapped and I have to say in this
game everyone bought a really brought a
really good gift
ya know what are some of the gifts oh no
I hold up but you thought I was gonna
bring socks
yeah but yes yes so what are the other
guys say I want to say it yeah hurt me
Nalani
it did yeah yeah let's just know we were
hurt oh I could I just say the guy's
weird our gift was the last no one would
even touch ours like ours was like a
little bag like and then see it right
Scotch tea and let me ask you something
and no one kept it okay dude all right
we picked it and then oh no one picked
it yeah there to the it was like what do
you mean knowing it at the end everyone
just get looked at it and they looked
away because of the size
no Justin we thought it was gonna be
strong that's what he gives you the last
30 years of my life every time it's a
birthday it's either socks or box yeah
do you want me to go down the list go
down this one year with Swatch watch was
around I got him a nice watch watch and
I got him a cool pair of Levi's jeans
the kind that used to like and you know
what hurt me the most
what this last birthday we went to
Uniqlo and I got him some cool unique
clothes led true swim trunks shorts yeah
and I was you picked me up I was with so
I was in the backseat it was past your
thing and then I looked in the tag was
still on this is like a month later
yeah the tag was it was just on the
ground it was just on the ground and
like Gilbert what he gave so that kind
of hurt me a little bit but it's okay
did you get Bobby no you got Bobby a
Star Wars oh my god Bobby I Star Wars
they just threw it away yeah so you got
to get him practical thing no no no no
you have to give them specific things
but let's go back to the gift though if
you were hurt you
Aulani were hurt a little bit we picked
yours last no one paid and would know
eventually because it was a house so
when they opened it up what did they see
my mom picked that what was it just
explain to the people what it was it was
like movies and then look at me in the
eyes right now don't look at me in the
eyes right now okay that gift was that a
gift that you opened from another
[ __ ] pro-bono do you target we went
together to target and you bought it we
went halves on it
we went halves on it who said that they
they it was a give art there was a nice
gift no but somebody told me that that
wasn't that was a gift that she wants
speakers at a different white elephant
you know what you're growing and you
know I apologize to you all right I'm
sorry you you've helped this resentment
about these Uniqlo shorts how long has
that been it's been a while I don't hear
about honest I don't remember and you
know what was really what's even sadder
is that Steve a week before your
birthday asked me what size does he wear
he sent me pictures do you think he'd
like this or this he went out of his way
to do this for you yeah yeah but you
know what don't feel bad I know I know
I'll tell you why because when you were
maligned I know you when you were blind
a lot of cash look at me when you're on
doesn't stop for a second I when you
were [ __ ] blind remember when you're
blind Bryce why you laughing yeah Bryce
you're supposed right team ten now can
you see Bryce Steve can you see yeah
okay okay so i gave you site I know I
know okay
no Jesus Steve hold on we're not done
let me just get this out of the way
because you confronted with the nucleus
shorts you can affect an affinity I'm
not done yet
all right I love you so much when you
have ailments on your team what about
your teeth fall out nobody what did you
go to the dentist
no we don't leave brothers don't do this
yeah yeah to get it pulled yeah yeah
[ __ ] pull look at me yeah no no duck sit
down believe it
he's now seeing again I can't even
[ __ ] back in the day when we do
Pringles I got the Pringles who bought
the people who got the Pringles aren't
sit back down sit back down
out of control no sit down this is good
he wants to play games he won't play
Christmas games gift games
we're playing so anyway how was Arizona
let's talk about our dad come on
yeah oh you want to play tit for tat I
got you I'm armed though how long did I
have this [ __ ] nut how many years I mean
15 years I've had this on my body I'm
just a little bit more painful this yeah
come on yeah he's showing his Bobby
tattoo yeah I Love You Man you're on
here okay to the grave all right tell
you what you still want to play tit for
tat no no no I don't want to do it let's
not do this Ari guys maybe I shouldn't
come this is good it's good it's good no
I should have went home why why is
you're doing this man you know I want to
just be positive be positive new year
[Music]